what do men need to do in order to
become excellent
oh wow
um it's it's not complicated
um a good friend of mine uh John of
Modern Life dating uh says make money
make muscles learn game and half frame
uh basically and you don't have to be
rich right you don't have to be a
millionaire or a zillionaire you don't
have to be a Miami yacht owner but you
have to be financially shrewd we have a
lot of there are a lot of people in this
country who make six figures have
terrible credit I don't know if you've
ever seen the movie uh the boiler room
but of course there's a perfect scene in
that where he's like listen man a lot of
these guys make six figures every month
but they don't have the credit to
finance a Honda Accord you understand
what I mean and so part of part of
financial shrewdness is you know living
below your means Etc et cetera uh
muscles uh physical fitness man that is
the Cornerstone of every man's
masculinity clearly I'm not quite as
quite as masculine as I need to be but
nothing will nothing will change your
life quicker than getting yourself into
shape the way you walk the way you talk
the way you feel the way people treat
you the way people perceive you all of
that changes
um game game is is is shorthand for
understanding women and dealing with
them the way they are there are a lot of
people uh out in the ethos who want to
they want to they want they want women
to step into a time machine and go back
to 1950. that's not happening unless doc
Emmett Brown comes back and Marty McFly
Back to the Future women are not going
back to 1950 and so my message is to I'm
not about complaining about women I did
that for years it's I went through a
stage it is what it is but if you really
want long-lasting healthy relationships
you're going to have to understand that
women today are not the way they were
back in 1950 and 1950s not coming
anytime soon you need to learn to deal
with things as they are and as far as
frame is concerned uh just basic
stoicism uh this is something that I
lack
um I'm I'm self-aware I'm self-aware
enough to understand that I lack a lot
of the whole frame components but frame
is basically standing ten toes down not
allowing people to move you off your
Square using false rhetoric things of
that nature so that's that's really what
uh in my opinion that's what masculinity
is all about awesome money muscles game
and framing compared frame to stoicism
yeah and if I can define stoicism and
I've read Marcus Aurelius oh wow
principles uh it's essentially life's
tough [ __ ] deal with it that's right
okay you know a lot of young men uh come
after guys who are like that they say
well it's hard for us out here and blah
blah blah blah listen I get it life is
tough for men because it needs to be
um this is why the concept of
unconditional love is dangerous and I'll
put it to you like this and and we can
move on if if women truly loved
unconditionally then everyone would look
like me right now because the reason why
do men do anything Andy Sandberg was on
The Late Night show a long time ago and
he said well what got you into uh into
comedy he said well why do we do
anything it's girls men we build for
women we go to Wars for women we
innovate for women we do everything for
women there's nothing wrong with
admitting that and so if women truly
love men unconditionally then the best
breeds would be the best jeans would be
bred out of out of the population within
a couple of generations because women
would be in love with fat slobs who
don't do anything so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here